the jurogan experience
let's go to your store okay so like
explain to everybody what happened with
you okay
um
well i mean i'm not sure how about how
far back you want me to start but
how you getting kicked off twitter let's
okay so i mean i was one of the
only
people in canada who was talking about
gender identity critically um i'm not
saying that to big myself up it was very
annoying because i obviously was like
targeted so there's jordan peterson
who spoke out and then there was me and
then there was like a couple other
people and i was pretty vocal about it
um
i first started talking about it back in
like
2016-2017 because the liberal government
was pushing through bill c-16 which was
our gender identity legislation um so
they were they were trying to and
succeeded in because the bill passed
incorporate gender identity into the
um human rights code
and the criminal code and i went and
testified against that bill
to say like this bill shouldn't pass um
it'll have a negative impact on women's
rights which for people who don't know
what the bill what it means could you
explain what it means because some folks
aren't hip to the argument right sorry
and also that canada we should explain
canada does not have a first amendment
so you don't have freedom of speech over
there you have a human rights council
right so and then
if laws
violate
if rather some of your speech violates
the laws that they put in place you can
literally be arrested
yeah you can you go through a human
rights tribunal
um and so
i mean
the law didn't actually it was very
vague like it didn't specifically say
for example you know if you misgender
somebody that's a hate crime or hate
speech or something like that all it did
was to say that gender identity and
gender expression essentially needed to
be protected under the law just like
whatever race
um other sort of marginalized identities
or whatever
um
and
what we thought would happen which did
happen is that it would sort of direct
policy um and it would mean that
you know
anybody could use any bathroom or change
room it would mean that men would have
to be allowed in transition houses and
women's shelters if they identified as
women
it would mean that men could be
transferred to female prisons if they
identified as women essentially like
to me the concept of gender identity
nullifies sex like you can't have both
you can't say
either you are a woman
and you're a woman because you're female
or you identify as a woman you can't you
can't do both and then anybody of course
can identify as a woman um i'm sort of
going about this a long way but um
yeah i was just worried about the
implications uh i testified at the
senate jordan peterson testified are you
okay yeah
and so essentially like i was the
loudest feminist voice in canada um
by far and i was tweeting about these
issues um i was asking questions about
gender identity i was sort of saying
like what does this mean like i said one
of the tweets that i my account was
locked down for was
what's the difference between a man and
a trans woman
um and i wasn't saying that to try to be
rude right um i was saying like somebody
please explain what happens to a man
between him being a man and then him
being a trans woman
do you know what i mean like if he
hasn't had any surgeries or anything
like that not that i think that a
surgery can change your sex but like
what is it so now yesterday he was a man
today he identifies as a woman or a
trans woman what's happened here
like what does this mean like it was
just so nonsensical it's just a belief
system well it can get even worse right
but you you can decide to go back and
forth throughout the day
yeah i mean people have they've allowed
that this is this is also accepted like
you you can be gender fluid and you
could be gender fluid depending upon
your mood
multiple times a day right
and
yeah and that's what the concept of
gender identity does it's just an
identity it's just something you say
right like it could be something you
feel but it's just a proclamation
there's no material
reality involved there's nothing
concrete there's nothing you can point
to
um
you know essentially like it's it's akin
to a religion as far as i'm concerned
it's faith-based right um so
you know i feel like these laws are
in a way
sort of enforcing religion on people
like it's like they're enforcing this
like faith-based woke religion yeah
yeah yeah yeah a lot of ways i mean
you could call it progressive but it's
of course not progressive it's just
weird and nonsensical and has a terrible
impact on women but um
so one of the tweets that i was locked
down for was that one you know what's
the difference between a man and a trans
woman
um just a question yeah and so they
suspended you for that so they yeah they
lock down my account and they're like
you have to delete this tweet if you
want your account back i appealed it it
was every time i've appealed anything
it's just been totally ignored they
don't explain why they never tell me
what rules i break either or did break
right like they never said they say
hateful conduct but they don't say oh
it's this specific rule like you're not
allowed to misgender or dead name or
whatever it would be i mean i don't even
know what rule that would break saying
like what's the difference between a man
and a trans woman
um
the other tweet of course was men aren't
women
which wasn't targeted at anybody i
wasn't saying you're not a woman
it was like part of a thread it was part
of a conversation that was back and
forth and i was like but men aren't
women
that was one of them that got me locked
down again
and then crazy well yeah like we're
literally like denying biology i mean so
what i think i don't know because again
no one's really explained anything to me
no one from twitter has communicated
with me no one said what i did wrong so
i'm just guessing can i tell you what
they said yeah they said that you were
told to delete the tweet
but you took a screenshot of it and you
deleted it but then reposted the
screenshot i did do that i didn't know
that i wasn't allowed to do that when i
did that so i wasn't trying to be a dick
like i wasn't trying to be like [ __ ] you
i was so mad i was like are you [ __ ]
serious like i got banned for saying
like men are women for asking these
really basic questions that was their
justification to me as to why they
banned you for the rest of your life
well fair
[ __ ] bananas yeah you're the there's
the example that i bring up when i talk
about this idea that you can just ban
people for saying things that are
factually correct
maybe politically insensitive
you know dependent upon the current
climate but factually correct
biologically correct scientifically
correct
maybe you might say that it's not kind
like but
what is wrong with being but are we
really deciding
that
there's certain rules that we want to
apply in regards to
progressive thinking that bypass or
supersede biology
is that what we're doing because when
you say a man if you say
a man is never a woman that's what you
said
men aren't women men are women men
aren't women that's a fact men are not
women
now
i believe in trans women i think there
are people that have gender dysphoria
and i think there are people that are
happier if they identify as a woman
dress as a woman are treated like a
woman or
or
you know use a woman's name and people
describe them as a woman it's it's
obviously real right they're they
obviously exist i think i mean
sure like i could buy
that there's such a thing as gender
dysphoria so you have some kind of like
mental condition or mental illness i'm
not trying to be mean i swear to god
like people get like triggered if you
say like a mental illness but i'm like
you literally think you're something
that you're not like you literally
believe you're a male you actually
believe you're a woman that's a form of
mental illness fine it doesn't mean
you're a bad person and i don't care
what if you want to dress in women's
clothes if you want to wear makeup if
you want to get cosmetic surgeries if
you want to change your name go for it
like do whatever makes you feel better
that's fine but i'm not going to lie
to comfort you or whomever else um so i
don't even agree that like gender
dysphoria means there's such a thing as
a trans woman like to me i'm still like
this concept doesn't make any sense
what's a trans woman like what does it
mean do you have to be on hormones do
you have to have a bunch of surgeries do
you have to have like a neo vagina it's
weird because like there's it's very
strict that you must accept that people
are trans women but then like what
defines a trans woman is completely open
to interpretation it's it's the the
person who decides whatever identity
they
identify with male female whatever it is
it's up to them it's up to them whether
they have surgery it's up to them
whether they take hormones it's up to
them whatever you can do absolutely
nothing you could have a full beard
and say you're a woman with a penis
functional testicles no problem at all
and you could say you're a woman and
everyone has to agree speaking of which
um the
the final
tweet that i was actually banned for so
they locked me down for those two things
right and then the final straw for them
was when i said yeah it's him in
reference to jessica yaniv who was once
jonathan
um if you recall he was the the man in
vancouver who was going around to local
estheticians and asking them to give him
a brazilian bikini wax yeah um and he
is fully a man i mean fully man intact
testicles intact penis yeah everything i
mean beard
and also a crazy person and a major
[ __ ] creep like and he's messaging
these women on face facebook um i think
sometimes under like a fake photo and
name so maybe with like a woman's photo
and woman's name that's not him and then
they would realize that he was a man i
guess maybe if they talk to him on the
phone or something like that and they'd
be like no sorry like we don't offer
this service to men and he would accuse
him of transphobia and essentially try
to extort money out of them
and when that didn't work i guess he
decided he wanted to i mean again he's a
crazy person so we can't take this as
representative very much other than the
fact that he's like a grifter and a
crazy person but you know to take them
all to the human rights tribunal
um to say he's being discriminated
against but this is exactly exactly the
perfect example of what happens if you
just say anybody is a woman and you just
have to accept it he has a penis he has
balls he obviously looks like a man at
that time he was still using his male
name um in various places like on
facebook some other places i think on
twitter at that time he was
maybe using both names um but it there
was there was nothing to show me that he
was a woman so i said yeah it's him i
figured out that it was him
um
and then i was permanently banned yeah
and that was in november
and that was it i appealed they were
like nope sorry hateful conduct again
didn't tell me what rule i broke 20
minutes after i was banned i was banned
on friday night i was at the bar i was
like what the [ __ ] i'm trying to have
fun um 20 minutes after i was banned
pink news which is like a like lgbt
queer news site um
they post an article saying twitter has
a new rule against misgendering and dead
naming
and i was like oh this is a really funny
coincidence that this went out 20
minutes after i was banned for some rule
that they didn't specify but i can only
assume was misgendering
yeah
misgendering a man who's a predator and
who was still going by his male name in
various places on the internet
whoops so i mean he should have been
bound to for misgendering himself good
point thank you it's it's just so weird
because it's the one area
that there's no room for
oh there's no room for interpretation
there's no room for
debate or nuance it's just like you
cannot miss gender you cannot dead name
you cannot like and you're cruel and
horrible if you do
yeah they're cruel and horrible to you
well yeah i mean the things that people
aren't banned for on twitter i mean i
have been like subject to countless
death threats like you should die you
get the wall you should go to the gulag
like people show you know like people
say horrible things to me online i
honestly don't care like i'm like it's
the internet people say horrible things
i'm not gonna crumble or feel hoarder
offended because somebody says some
[ __ ] to me on twitter
but you can't even say
he
to somebody who's declared themselves a
woman or you're essentially guilty of
hate speech but they can call you stupid
[ __ ] and worse yeah and believe it or
not what's worse like [ __ ] i don't know
there you go
kill yourself you turf [ __ ]
i've gotten interested
trans exclusionary radical feminist yeah
yeah
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify